by David Sirota who is the author of
hostile takeover and before we get into
the book want to talk to you a little
bit about what Hugo guerdon was talking
about and that's k street hedging the
bets on the outcome of the next election
in two thousand six and two thousand
eight what do you think about that well
I think it's not surprising as my book
goes into the corruption on Capitol Hill
the influence of big money on Capitol
Hill crosses both parties and so I think
that that the overt nature of K Street
moving a little bit towards the
Democratic Party is not that surprising
because they haven't necessarily
divested themselves fully of Democrats
even though there was the K Street
project in other words that that they're
reasserting themselves with the
Democratic Party I think shouldn't be
shocking because I think big money has
always played an influence and continues
to play in info influence on both
parties regardless of the high-profile
nature of the recent corruption scandals
as focused on the Republican Party the
name of the book hostile takeover how
big money and corruption conquered our
government and how we take it back the
reading through this book how surprised
would people be to see that in in your
opinion that there is big money in both
the Democratic Party and the Republican
Party well I don't think people will be
surprised I think that what they will be
surprised about is how deeply rooted
corruption really is as I argue you know
we tend to think of corruption as Jack
Abramoff do Cunningham and the scandals
that we read about in the paper and is
that as the book makes the point that
that corruption really is far deeper
than that the worst forms of corruption
what's legal what's happening every day
in fact I would actually argue that
corruption is even how we frame the
debate so for instance on energy policy
as as gas prices hit three dollars a
gallon as as Exxon Mobil reports eight
billion dollars in profits while they're
giving their CEO a 400 million dollar
retirement package up until very
recently the terms of the debate have
been essentially what tax breaks to give
to
energy companies up until very recently
any policies that would actually
challenge big money in this case big oil
like a windfall profits tax like a
federal price gouging law that's been
out of the debate and so I would argue
that that's out of the debate not
accidentally it's deliberate it's
deliberate from a Congress that is in
part owned by the big oil companies so
if there is nothing illegal no price
gouging anything like that going on how
does Congress get involved with
ExxonMobil for example who wants to give
their retiring CEO a 400 million dollar
retirement package well two ways first
of all I'm not sure that there's nothing
illegal going on in the book I document
how internal oil industry memos in the
late 90s and early 2000s were trying to
limit their refining capacity in order
to create artificial bottlenecks so have
we seen a serious investigation into
that no we have it have we seen a
consideration of a windfall profits tax
that's a way to to try to rein in a
price gouging through a windfall profits
tax I think you know have we seen even a
discussion about really repealing
already passed tax cuts for companies
like Exxon Mobil what we saw it it
lasted about three days now we're not
talking about it again why again because
companies like Exxon Mobil have a huge
amount of discretionary money to throw
around Washington to make sure that
these policies never get debated we're
talking with David Sirota author of
hostile takeover how big money and
corruption conquered our government and
how we take it back and I want for you
to we'd like for you to get involved in
the conversation and we'll show you the
numbers on the screen just a few seconds
first we're going to take this call from
Columbus Ohio on our line for Democrats
good morning good morning sir I agree
which is big money and both parties but
the Republicans seem to be up I mean
just obscene with the manner in which
they allow the abuse to be take place in
government and I want to get to a couple
of points they always talking about the
market the free market but what the
consumer or the voter has an opportunity
to take advantage of the market they
always change the rules like the free
market in employment okay when when
demand for labor is high then they let
uh immigrants come across they change
the rules all the time they'll say a
free market in oil once it was regulated
it said we're going to deregulate it
then they changed the rules all the time
to cut down the supply I mean if people
don't see this here it is it's it's
almost obscene what they do today it
changed the rules but it's always a free
market when it is vanished for the
corporate of the corporate enterprises
but when it's time for the consumer to
take advantage of the the environment
the media be a financial environment
they changed the rules every time I
would I would tend I would absolutely
agree with you and as my book goes into
one of the great myths in this country
pushed by big money interest is that we
actually live in a free market here's a
part of my book which actually goes into
exactly this question in one breath
politicians tell us that price controls
for instance for prescription drugs are
bad that's that's anti free market yet
they pass restrictive patent laws that
an anti free-market provision that keep
drug prices high they tell us
regulations against energy price gouging
would be against the free market but
government handouts taxpayer handouts to
big oil companies you know a subsidy not
a free market policy we're told that
that's good protecting American jobs
that's against the free market that's
what we're told we shouldn't Pat we
shouldn't try to protect American jobs
but government helping companies
outsource through subsidisation
outsourcing through subsidization we're
told that that's fine that's fine forget
about the free market when it comes to
that so in other words you're absolutely
right the entire mantra of the concept
that we live in a free market right now
that is I would argue a myth when the
free market only serves to work for
corporate interest but doesn't work for
ordinary citizens you should know that
we don't actually live in a free market
we live in
rigged market next up is Yucca Valley
California on our line for Republicans
good morning up yes you know we're
talking about corruption when we find
out that a lot of our representatives
and our politicians are come out of the
corporate world to represent us is there
anything that the American people or the
honest politicians that are there to
serve the people which i think is that
the precept of getting into politics is
there anything we can do to or people
like you watchdogs to expose this and I
know the media won't that that their
hands are still in the corporate world
and I mean their hands are out because
they seem to when they do their tenure
and I hate to say this but we throw them
out like our administration right now
being so connected up with the oil that
should we put a man on the moon in 1969
with what is now antiquated technology
it seems to me you know going back to
the last speaker who used a lot of words
but he seems to put down the ethanol oh
they have ethanol concept this is the
breadbasket of America why can't we have
a have these politicians or or somebody
wake up to the fact to let the American
people if we develop our energy sources
here and there's many different ways
that that I know they don't want us to
be independent of them because we're on
their corporate tit David Sirota well I
think the the caller asked a good
question how do we actually take it back
as I told a friend of mine recently if I
written this book 10 years from now I
would probably change the subtitle to
read
how big money and corruption conquered
our government period I wouldn't have a
section on how we take it back you're
absolutely right there is a lot of
corporate influence in government the
revolving door is spinning wildly out of
control we're now seeing to the point
where lobbyists are actually running for
office and winning Senator John Thune
for instance was a corporate lobbyists
before becoming a senator you know mitch
Daniels in Indiana he was a executive
vice president of a giant drug company
so you're absolutely right how do we
take it back well I would argue
fundamentally that we need campaign
finance reform and not the kind of
campaign finance reform we've seen I
think we need public financing of
Elections I think we need to give people
who want to run for office a way to run
where they don't have to be specialists
in shaking down big money interests now
I know the criticism of that is well its
welfare for politicians well my answer
to that is you get what you pay for
somebody's going to pay for these
elections somebody is paying for these
elections big-money interests are paying
for these elections and Congress works
for big money interests if we want a
government that works for us we have to
finance our campaigns if we can spend a
billion or a billion and a half dollars
a year promoting democracy abroad I say
we can afford to spend at least half
that promoting and here at home next up
is Knoxville Tennessee on our line for
independence good morning a good morning
mr. sirota appreciate your book I agree
with you and I wanted to point out to
the people that the biggest contributors
in 04 to the Bush campaign was
pharmaceuticals and then we've had the
prices go up and up and the second
biggest contributors were the worthy
energy and oil companies to the
Republicans so if people wonder why gas
prices are going up they should look at
that and they're used when Clinton left
office there were 12 large oil companies
and the Justice Department under our
current administration has allowed them
all to merge so now there's only five
big energy companies like ConocoPhillips
and all that and there's not the
competition and I want you to comment on
how that's affected gas prices but
they're just not the competition there
used to be well I you're absolutely
right consolidation and vertical
integration in the in the energy
industry has been a huge problem it's
something that that was moving moving
forward under the Clinton administration
where but it has absolutely accelerated
under the Bush administration the stats
about how fast its accelerated are in my
book but but here's a telling example of
exactly how in the pocket of the oil
companies our government really is I
think it was two years ago President
Bush had the nerve to nominate a tech a
chevron texaco lawyer to head the
Federal Trade Commission this is the
Commission that's supposed to be
investigating oil industry price gouging
this is the Commission that's supposed
to regulate and prevent anti-competitive
anti free market mergers in the oil
industry it is again now headed by a
former chevron texaco lawyer so this
shows you how mundane and how regular
and how deeply rooted corruption is in
our government as I said at the
beginning of this it's not necessarily
what's illegal that's the worst forms of
corruption it's with legal who better
though to know how business law should
be adjudicated than somebody who's been
in business well I would argue that that
there's a problem with allowing folks
who come straight out of a regulated
industry to become the regulator so I
think you're right business experience
is important however I would also say as
a side note that there are plenty of
experts who work in the nonprofit and
watchdog world that I would argue would
be better but even but you're right
folks who have business experience is
important the question is should the
revolving door be allowed to spin
immediately should you be allowed to
immediately go from a regulated industry
to a regulator I would say no and in
Montana the state where I now live we
have a ballot measure that would prevent
for instance lobbyists I'm sorry
legislators from immediately becoming
lobbyists in Congress I know that the
the law is something around something
along the lines of you can't Lobby your
office for I think it's about a year the
problem is you can co lobby everybody
else's office so the point is is that
you're right business experience is
important I would say it's not the only
factor right now it seems to be the only
factor but what's more important is how
how fast the revolving door moves it's
almost like nobody even thinks twice
about it anymore next up is Kingston
Oklahoma on our line for Republicans
you're talking with David Sirota author
of hostile takeover mr. Schroeder you
really have no idea what you're talking
about you look like a person that has
never earned a living in his life now if
you lived in a place like Oklahoma where
we had I live in Montana I live in
Montana well but if you have ever lived
where there was oil like Oklahoma
there's no whale in Montana there's
probably oil in Montana yes but you see
we don't do that we don't do that
anymore we haven't built a refinery in
30 years the reason we haven't built
refinery in 30 years is because of the
EPA and OSHA and all of these other
organizations that have come up to keep
keep us from developing our own energy
resources and I can assure you that
regardless of what the resources are
soon they will ban a fertilizer put on
the ground in order to grow more corn
because we cannot grow our way out of
this we need to drill we have drill how
many people do you think up to Anwar and
see that that wilderness up there
there's not one person out of every
hundred thousand that ever sees that and
why don't we take advantage of the
resources that we have and use them and
forget about the oil companies making
money because they're going to that's
why you get in business now did you
write that book to donate all of the
proceeds of it to charity no you didn't
write that book for charity you wrote
that book for you and you're taking
every cent that you can get out of it
and you're using it yourself that's
called capitalism there's nothing wrong
with that that was an interesting
interesting diatribe
let's go to the Anwar question first the
idea that that Anwar will will get us
off foreign oil well here's your
government here's what they say that if
we opened up Anwar we would America's
dependence on oil would go from
sixty-two percent to just sixty percent
if you want to know how to use our
resources how about fuel efficiency
standards fuel efficiency standards our
own government tells us would produce as
much oil savings per year that Anwar has
in its entirety that's the first
question the the issue of refining
capacity we heard another myth here that
it's all the environmental regulations
and oh we should feel bad for the oil
companies boy I I feel real bad for the
oil companies when in fact in my book
you will see documented internal oil
industry memos which show that the oil
industry has deliberately limited its
refining capacity memos between
executives saying we are going to limit
our refining capacity in order to boost
prices and consumers union a nonpartisan
watchdog group well-respected on both
sides of the aisle reports that refining
that that the refining capacity issue is
responsible for at least thirty to
thirty-five percent of this spike in oil
prices so before we go off into some
wild theory about environmental laws
parroted from from a right-wing
operation let's remember what the facts
are the refining capacity in this
country is being gamed it's being gained
to make sure that companies like Exxon
make eight billion dollars a year next
up is Batesville Mississippi good
morning good morning how y'all gentlemen
is doing good thank you yes I think you
know exactly what he tell them out
unlike the gentleman from Oklahoma well
in a way gasps here is like three
dollars together in a way the air is
personally Mississippi minimum wage
makes 515 harrods we posed to make it we
guessed is high that's my only question
now just colony that's a that's a that's
a very good question the minimum wage
has reached a 50-year low Congress
refuses to to raise the minimum wage
we hear all sorts of lies about how the
minimum wage is supposedly going to hurt
the economy my favorite lie that's told
is that the the minimum wage is going to
drive down job growth of course there
are studies that have consistently shown
that states that have raised their
minimum wage actually are adding jobs
faster than states that haven't whenever
the minimum wage comes up for a vote we
get a proposal like we saw last year
from senator Rick Santorum that
purported to raise the minimum wage gave
Republicans a way to vote for it pretend
that they were supported it meanwhile
that bill would have actually eliminated
minimum wage protections for roughly 8
million workers so we see again Congress
in the pocket of big money interests and
no consideration for the kinds of
situations you're talking about high gas
prices low wages Congress in the pocket
doing nothing in terms of big money and
corruption is one party better at it or
bigger at it than another party or is it
more situation of the party in power
versus the party out of power I would I
would argue that we've always had one
big business party in this country and
we always will have one big business
party in this country I would say the
problem is how have we reached a point
where we really I would argue have are
undergoing a hostile takeover of the
whole government well I would say it's
because we have about one and a third or
one and a quarter big business parties
that a quarter to a third of the
Democratic Party is part of the problem
and that has allowed the entire debate
to shift radically towards corporate
America's wishes so I guess in terms of
percentages I would say there are more
people within the Democratic Party in
Washington who are fighting the hostile
takeover then there are within the
Republican Party but again I think we
need to get out of the paradigm of red
and blue democrat and republican and
realize that what the real paradigm is
is folks with money that have enough
money to buy a seat at the table and
folks without it and the people with
money in a system that that forces
politicians to run by being financed by
big money is going to skew towards big
money and not towards the people next up
is lockport illinois on our line for
republicans you're on with david sirota
hi hi uh let's see I have a book to read
by Buckminster Fuller is published about
nineteen eighty and it's called critical
path and in that book he discusses
foreign aid money now foreign aid money
supposedly according to four as strings
attached to it if you send the foreign
aid money overseas it has to benefit a
US company not only the country a ghost
of a test test be spent with I'm us
products so one of the things that
happens I understand is you could close
the plant up here in the US and like
will say company X and it can move
overseas and the US government under the
guise foreign aid will build company X
the new plants overseas I've called my
representative on this I've called
senators I've written newspapers no one
will give me an answer if this is still
going on I can give you an answer that
it's it's it's in the same realm this
book doesn't touch on the foreign aid
question but it does touch on job
outsourcing and our government support
for it let me give you some examples of
how our government is spending your
taxpayer money to help to help
outsourced jobs you may recall that that
back two years ago the White House
actually issued an official government
report endorsing job outsourcing
president bush signed his name to it you
might recall a bunch of stories about a
year and a half ago about how the
administration was holding forums across
the country at hotels like the Waldorf
Astoria in New York encouraging
companies to move their operations to
China and perhaps worst of all is that
little thing called the export-import
bank this is a bank funded with billions
of dollars of your taxpayer money it's
supposed to be going to subsidize
companies who are marketing their
products overseas what we end up finding
out is that it's subsidizing companies
that are simultaneously reducing their
jobs here at home and increasing their
jobs overseas that is outsourcing their
operations bipartisan legislation was
brought forward to stop subsidies that
go to corporations that are a limb
nating their US workforce and increasing
their workforce elsewhere that
bipartisan legislation was voted down
the fact that it was voted down should
be everything you need to know about
what our government really feels about
job outsourcing in this country David
Sirota born in New Haven Connecticut
grew up in the Philadelphia suburbs now
lives in Helena Montana how does a guy
from the east coast end up in Big Sky
Country well I i worked for brian
schweitzer in two thousand when he ran
against conrad burns for the US Senate
he was a farmer first-time candidate and
I had a chance to go out there and work
for him and we remained good friends and
come 2004 he decided to run for governor
and he he asked me to come out for the
tail end of the campaign which I did I
served as a strategist to Schweitzer and
he became the first Democratic governor
in that state in 16 years in a same year
that the state voted sixty percent for
George Bush so after the election my
wife and I decided that we'd like to
have an adventure and move out to
Montana and it's been it's been a
wonderful experience back to the phone
San Saba Texas go ahead hello good show
man I was a rape upper 70 fun we had oil
shortage and at that time the government
would lag 4,200 said aloud and but the
first thing you had a bailout here it
made three hundred barrels of oil a day
or a month or whatever but the first
hundred barrels that will made that a
ten-dollar sparrow then the second
hundred barrels is that well maybe pay
eight dollars a barrel third third six
dollars let's ring her up so what the
pumpers would do they'd go out there the
tough but will he get hot dogs get four
hundred barrels shut that well down the
recent mud which create short that will
had good pumps purple water barrel of
all that he's created short local tech
scrutiny
it worked up short I it's an interesting
topic and I have a section in my book
about what's actually causing price
spikes and and as you'll see in the book
it shows that that the fluctuations and
prices don't really have anything to do
at least in the short term with crude
oil prices again it has to do with
artificial shortages there was a study
done by consumers union again about
about California about a year ago about
why their gas prices were going up and
the study showed that it had everything
to do with artificial shortages this in
this case created by by artificial
bottlenecks and refining capacity but I
think the issue is we need to get out of
thinking only in terms of oil I think we
need to ask more fundamental questions
why is our government after experiencing
these shortages of the 70s why are we
not focused on more sustainable policies
why are we not really focused on raising
fuel efficiency standards why are we not
focused on developing alternative
sources of energy why why was Jimmy
Carter for instance ridiculed 25 or 30
years ago for talking about this stuff
and then we didn't do anything and now
we're sitting here at the same at the
same place the question for us is are we
going to allow a corrupt government to
let us languish here in this same place
for the next 10 years or 20 years or 30
years or are we going to finally say
it's time to end both America's
addiction to oil and Congress's
addiction to oil money mountain home
arkansas you've got the last question
for David Sirota yes please excuse me
I'm a little nervous I want to just
start off it I want people to get off
this one person who is our president I
want them to get off his back everything
is his fault the outsourcing of business
to other country started a long long
time ago not doing Josh Bush's
presidency and also during the Carter
years we were I was missing days to go
to work I had to drive 45 miles because
I couldn't get gas tear gas lines we
were running out of gas at the stations
but I believe the people should be
allowed to a drill and Alaska and and it
is certain something that the senator
from Alaska wants the people of Alaska
want is the reason why we don't have oil
the final is enough to find the coat in
our country is because is because the
environmentalists have been preventing
disk this sort of things to happen X for
your call ma'am it really shows the
power of the propaganda system that's
out there the idea that it's a radical
environmentalists who are creating the
oil crisis I mean that is absolutely
unbelievable that this is this is out in
the culture I it's not unbelievable if
you accept the fact that this is being
peddled by our government very
deliberately it's being peddled because
the oil industry has a lot of money to
make sure that politicians continue to
repeat this malarkey again if you look
in my book you will see the facts from
our government that show that this is
not a problem of environmentalism this
is a problem of oil industry price
gouging David Sirota author of hostile
takeover big money and corruption and
how big money and corruption conquered
our government and how we take it back
thank you for being on the program
thanks for having me and thanks for
watching this edition of the Washington
journal we go live now to the House of
Representatives